[Music]
the quarterback position we have a
starter in Eli and we've got guys behind
him specifically Daniel Jones that need
to do everything you can to get ready to
plate you know week one and that's where
Pat Shermer coach of the Giants making
it clear on Monday that Eli Manning is
the starter the other guys are gonna
have to get ready but you know you
always have to be ready to play but it
looks like the Giants aren't ready to go
with anyone other than Eli Manning and
that's the first topic in today's word
association game Chris Sims when I say
Pat Shermer claims that Eli is the
starter in New York your reaction is
what duh I mean duh yes that's what my
it's Captain Obvious I mean again
there's been nothing that the Giants
have shown are done to say that they are
just not gonna have total blind loyalty
to Eli Manning it doesn't matter he's
got nine lives or 18 lives or how many
you want to say but again this is one
playoff appearance since the 2011 Super
Bowl you know it's way below 500 record
but they have continued to stay loyal
and this is what I expected and I don't
expect a lie to come out at any point
early in the season unless they go one
in four to and five maybe then they
start to think about making a change
yeah I mean my reaction is the Giants
still have no plan how can you use the
sixth overall pick in the draft on a
quarterback and not at least give him a
chance to earn the job right out of the
gates this isn't the Chiefs in 2017 when
Patrick mahomes was a clear luxury pick
Daniel Jones is a need pick they need
someone better than Eli Manning Eli
Manning is not one of the top 20
quarterbacks in the NFL right now Eli
Manning is in decline the only people
who don't seem to realize it are the
Giants except when it was time to
exercise the sixth overall pick in the
draft Chris that's what is so odd to me
on one hand they drafted daniel Jones
sixth overall on the other hand they're
still blindly loyal and yeah so yeah it
with Eli Manning it's just I don't get
it I just don't get it no I'm with you
Mike I don't I don't think a lot of
people in the NFL get it either but
again it they've shown that this is the
way they are and they're gonna try to
make it work with Eli before they move
on
alright there was some confusion last
week Doug Peterson the coach of the
Eagles a little bit coy about whether or
not Carson Wentz is starting quarterback
would be ready for OTAs now reportedly
Carson Wentz has no limitations from the
back injury that wiped out the end of
his 2018 season he'll be ready to go for
OTAs your reaction back them off I mean
that's what you like that little play on
words there you know because he had the
battery well it's okay maybe you need to
go to another lawyer school and figure
that one out okay but no I mean hey yeah
I mean back him off because he needs to
back off some of the haters as far as
the media the public the fan base who
were saying Nick Foles should be the
quarterback right this should be the guy
going forward we won a Super Bowl with
Nick Foles so he's got to get people
like that off his back to show again
that he can he's capable of being
healthy and being the starter he's also
got to get the team rallied back around
him too I mean he made some comments a
few weeks ago
you know self-assessing thyself which I
really appreciate and and recognize that
he could be a better leader in the
locker room and communicate better so I
think this goes a long way to the first
step to mending those relationships and
becoming the man once again in
Philadelphia yeah I mean my reaction is
shoulder shrug because I don't care if
he's healthy now what I care about is is
he healthy when it counts November
December January will he be available to
the team this year if he plays
wire-to-wire he's a clear MVP candidate
he he's my favorite if he's able to play
for the full regular season I just have
seen nothing to cause me to believe that
he can so healthy in May okay fine
you're supposed to be as a quarterback
will you be healthy when it really
matters in December or will the Eagles
be finding out what they have innate son
felt or Thurston Howell the third
whoever the guy is
how about Kliff Kingsbury he talked
yesterday about quarterback Tyler Murray
and cliff Kings very very excited that
Conor Murray's sports attention no
longer diluted by baseball football only
Kingsbury said that Murray has never
done that in his entire life so I want
to see how much we can accelerate the
rookie learning curve and how much
growth we can get over the next two
eight or
9 months Chris Sims your response I you
know said this word association uh
untapped potential I mean that you know
singular focus it's the first time ever
that the guys putting all his eggs and
playing quarterback and I understand
we're cliffed Kings or he's coming there
you know this is this is a guy that you
know more times than not this time of
the years start to worries about it
start to worry about his his his
baseball swing and Mechanics for
baseball what could make him a better
player that way now he has a chance to
focus on football only football get into
the playbook get into the finer
mechanics that can make him better at
playing that position so I would I would
expect the growth to happen pretty fast
and as you and I have talked about a lot
he knows this offense so I don't think
this is gonna be hard for him to catch
up and and really get ahold of what
they're teaching there in Arizona well
I'm just confounded I can't even think
of a word to associate yeah because he's
not like he was playing baseball last
fall right he was only focused on
football once he showed up for training
season right III know I know but but
still he's yeah I yeah yeah yeah I just
look he's a great baseball player he's a
great football player I don't think that
setting aside baseball suddenly makes
you a better football player I don't
know how much better it's gonna make you
I really don't you you kind of are who
you are now is he going to be tab more
time at his disposal Lerner and I felt
defenses yes but that's what being an
NFL quarterback is I don't know how much
more time you could devote to football
anyway at the college level because of
the limitations on how many hours you
cannot leave ever sorry I saw I think
it's a little bit of a red herring and
and it may be kind of a roundabout way
to reduce expectations he's saying over
the next eight or nine months which is
basically let's treat this like a
redshirt year kind of I mean he's gonna
play but let's not expect too much out
of him this year because he's still
learning the sport that's my big
takeaway from what Kingsbury sorry
that's good but this is word association
and we're gonna need your word before we
move on okay what's your yeah
I don't know let me think about it and
get back to you here let's move on to
the next one tom coughlin the jaguars
executive vp of football operations on
new quarterback nick foles he's out
there working just like everybody else
is that out there working and his
presence is what's important it's like
that thing I insinuate a lot don't tell
me
show me let's stop so much verbage and
let's work it your reaction Oh Tom
Coughlin the army general right there I
mean he's got some West Point ties to
him and that's what Tom Coughlin is you
know I think he he got a little
frustrated last year with Jacksonville
and maybe some of the talk that was
coming out of the locker room and some
of the antics that went on on the field
where he felt like yeah it was a little
you know all talk all braggadocio all
the time and he wants to see a little
bit more work ethic and I think he he's
saying that because he appreciates Nick
Foles there and I'm sure there's other
guys that are not there that he's trying
to you know kind of send out a little
warning sign to them to that it that it
pays to be here and working with the
football team yeah my reaction is it's
not about Falls this is about the guys
who are exactly right the yannick and
got way who reportedly is scheduled to
show up for OTAs a Dylan RAM Jalen
Ramsey right this is this you can't
criticize the guys who aren't there but
you can praise the guys who are there
and he already got himself a little
cross way he's got a warning from the
league because of the things he said
about the guys who weren't there earlier
in the off season program this is Tom
Coughlin's way to stick it back to the
league into the NFLPA for having an
issue with him calling out the guys who
aren't there you go over the top in
praising the guys who are there and and
really I think the Jaguars are gonna go
as far as Nick Foles can take them
earlier this week Jeffrey Lurie the
owner of the Eagles had a commencement
address and and praised Doug Peterson
and his empathy and emotional
intelligence and I'm telling you that's
what Nick Foles is gonna bring into that
locker room if he didn't already have it
he learned it from Peterson the
importance of having that individual
relationship with your teammates having
everyone feel like they're part of a
greater objective they're all working
together and not working for themselves
yeah that's what the Jaguars need in
their quarterback they need someone who
can bring that team together because if
they can Chris is enough talent there
that if they can play like a team if
they can be on the same page if they
don't resent the quarterback who's
getting kid-glove treatment even though
he stinks like they did with Blake
bortles as you believe out of there
that's I feel bad saying that but but
you believe it and I kind of believe it
too then maybe you can galvanize the
team and and be more like the team that
was 11 and 5 in 2017 not 5 and 11 and 28
he's got your I mean hey he's got some
presence about him that's the one thing
when Nick Foles when you turn on film
man he's a big guy he's fearless in the
pocket he makes throws he's got a
presence when he's walking on the
sidelines he's got a presence in the
locker room and especially when he got a
Super Bowl trophy and MVP to talk about
to that'll make guys look up to you even
more like you're some bright shiny
special object but hey he takes pressure
off the football team it's no longer
than have to be about oh we got to run
the ball and we got to really take care
of the ball in the passing game and not
make mistakes and let the defense win
the game no they got a guy that they're
gonna be able to trust to make plays
handle certain situations and as you've
heard me say about a lot of times I
think you're you're with me here I mean
we're both believers in Jacksonville
right I mean I look at Jacksonville if
you made me bet today I go Jacksonville
is going to the playoffs this year just
because of the talent they do have in
their football team and finally getting
the right quarterback in there
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports